et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
florence rault avocate pénaliste bonsoir
à vos côtés vincent berger avocat
spécialiste de droit international
alors avant de vous donner la parole je
vous propose de regarder un ce tweet
d'eric dupond-moretti
je suis pour que la justice soit
désormais totalement filmer et diffuser
la justice doit se montrer aux français
la publicité des débats est une garantie
démocratique alors la publicité des
débats est une garantie démocratique et
riz écrit par don eric dupond-moretti
alors est ce que le ministre de la
justice a raison est ce que la justice
doit s'ouvrir pour faire de la pédagogie
selon vous florence rault le ministre de
la justice nous dit que la justice doit
se montrer aux français alors moi je
suis absolument pour qu'on montre la
justice aux français mais je pense que
les français vont être extrêmement déçu
par l'état dans lequel se trouve notre
justice aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si
c'est une bonne idée de film et surtout
de diffuser ça pose un certain nombre de
problèmes film et pourquoi pas les
audiences mais lesquels est-ce que c'est
seulement les assises est ce que on ira
aussi dans les correctionnel pourquoi
pas mais que va-t-on faire avec les
procédures civiles dans lesquelles il ya
quand même un certain nombre de secrets
des affaires par exemple qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de dévoiler ni de montrer à tout le
monde
en revanche dans le procès pénal il ya
des choses qu'il serait parfaitement
bonne de filmer par exemple on filme
bien en matière criminelle les auditions
de témoins les auditions des accusés
lorsque nous sommes en enquête pourquoi
pas mais après pourquoi en faire pour
les diffuser les diffuser alors sur lui
j'ai bien compris sur une chaîne qui
serait dédié
ça existe peut-être dans d'autres pays
que le nôtre mais finale
man pourquoi faire en vrai et est-ce
qu'il n'ya pas et ça je crois quand même
que la réponse est assez positive est ce
qu'il n'ya pas d'autre idée à creuser
pour d'autres réformes qu'il serait
urgentissime de mener comme l'état
désastreux dans lequel se trouve notre
justice je donne juste un exemple mais
personnellement j'attends une décision
depuis un an et demi qui n'est pas
encore rédigée et qui n'est pas encore
signé par magistrats et c'est un
tribunal correctionnel de la région
parisienne qui a rendu cette décision
donc c'est un exemple mais il y en
aurait tellement d'autre qu' on en
aurait pas assez d'une seule soirée pour
raconter tout ce qui se passe dans cette
justice qui ne fonctionnent plus alors
qu'à voilà en tout cas on va rester un
justement sur cette volonté de filmer
les audiences alors vincent berger me
florence rault nous disait bien pourquoi
pas il ya il ya des choses effectivement
qu'on pourrait qu'il serait bon film et
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à ce que
c'est une proposition populiste qui
ferait peut-être basculé la justice dans
le spectacle alors contrairement à ma
consoeur pénaliste moi je ne suis pas un
avocat pénaliste
mais a priori je suis extrêmement
réservés vis-à-vis de cette proposition
moi je comprends parfaitement le soucier
du garde des sceaux de vouloir expliquer
aux tout grand public le fonctionnement
de la justice veut le déroulement des
audiences etc
mais je crois que le moyen qui le
propose n'est pas le plus adapté et même
par et là on a un petit problème de
liaison là juste à les hisser revenus
annonce nous avons donc je disais je
suis très réservé concernant cette
proposition qui me paraît assez
dangereuse en quelque sorte
moi je ne suis pas un avocat pénaliste
mais je même si l'on se contentait des
procédures pénales qui sont les plus
grands publics pour hafid et on voit mal
l'intérêt que ça apporterait au public
moi je comprends très bien soucis donc
du garde des sceaux de vouloir expliquer
à la population comment fonctionne la
justice parce que c'est un monde qui
pour la plupart de nos concitoyens est
un monde opaque un peu secret difficile
à comprendre avec ses différents acteurs
ces différentes procédures
ces différentes étapes et cetera donc
c'est quelque chose qui mérite d'être
expliquée mais je verrai ça davantage
dans le cadre scolaire ou peut-être même
universitaire que dans ce cadre là moi
je vois deux grands grande difficulté
même s'il on se contenter de la matière
pénale pour le respect de la vie privée
des personnes notamment le droit à
l'image
mais pas seulement le droit à l'image le
jeu je m'inquiéterais aussi beaucoup
pour la sécurité dans certaines
procédures pour les témoins pour là je
m'inquiéterais énormément aussi pour les
victimes
n'oubliez pas seulement les victimes
d'agressions sexuelles ou de viols mais
pour beaucoup d'autres questions
extrêmement grave et jeté en pâture
toutes ces personnes avec leurs vies
leurs inquiétudes et de leur souffrance
me paraît à porter atteinte à la dignité
des personnes
ça peut être effectivement dangereux de
vouloir filmer ses audiences aujourd'hui
oui ça peut être dangereux puis surtout
je ne vois pas l'utilité de
très tout cela aux gens ça les concerne
pas c'est pas parce que ce que les gens
veulent savoir c'est comment fonctionne
la justice
or la justice elle s'est complètement
refermée sur elle même
on n'a plus accès aux magistrats ont
vaincu accès au greffe on n'a plus accès
à rien on nous fait des palais de
justice qui sont de véritables bunkers
où vous avez si vous avez un badge est
autorisé et ils sont rares et chères
enfin qu'en argent bien sûr mais si vous
n'êtes pas autorisé vous ne rentrez
nulle part ça n'a plus aucun sens donc
d'une certaine manière on veut
vulgariser la justice on veut la montrer
aux français
ça c'est très loi on veut leur expliquer
comment ça marche
moi je suis toujours partante pour ça
pour expliquer les procédures et pour
dire aux gens ce qu'ils peuvent attendre
pas attendre mais maintenant avait
montré un procès sur une chaîne de télé
n'importe laquelle
à trop demander à n'importe qui je crois
que mon confrère a raison même si l'epa
pénaliste il touche effectivement des
points essentiels
pourquoi elle est dévoilé un certain
nombre de choses qui ne doit pas sûr
montrer à tout le monde qui n'a pas
forcément les outils pour comprendre
tout ça alors je vais tempéré mon propos
quand même parce que faisant exerçant en
droit pénal
c'est vrai que parfois j'aurais
tellement vu qu'un procès d'assises
soient filmés alors qu'on n'a pas le
droit de le faire j'aurais tellement
vide filmé certains échanges certain
regard certaines attitudes de certains
acteurs des procès et pas forcément les
victimes ou les enfin les gens qui
participent mais mais mais parfois
certains magistrats certains parquetier
voir comment les choses se déroulent et
pouvoir l'utiliser ensuite dans un
procès en appel
ça ça me paraît très très intéressant
jauzion les circonstances il me semble
que filmer les débats pour être finie
excellente chose mais pas forcément pour
ce que l'on veut en faire et elle que
cette annonce vincent berger
effectivement est ce que ça pourrait
faire finalement évoluer aussi le lin
l'institution le fait de rendre publics
tous ces débats peut-être mais le coût à
payer je viens de dire me paraîtrait
exorbitants
bien sûr parce que films et seulement
les juges quel serait l'intérêt
s'il met simplement l'accusé quel serait
l'intérêt là un procès c'est tout un
ensemble c'est une sorte de pièce de
théâtre avec de très nombreux acteurs
qui s'influencent mutuellement et donc
il sole et une seule un seul acteur ou
une seule catégorie d'acteurs serait à
mon avis ou aussi inacceptable donc moi
ce qu'il ne frappe beaucoup c'est que
c'est une des exigences de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme c'est
qu'il faut que le procès soit public et
naturellement les audiences
la plupart des audiences civiles mais
aussi de toutes les affaires le en
principe pénales sont accessibles au
public
ça permet aux citoyens qui veulent se
déplacer de contrôle est en quelque
sorte bon fonctionnement de la juge
alors on a évidemment d'importance mais
à mon avis jusqu'à exiger que les procès
soit filmé et diffusé sur le net
florence euros le mot de la fin
comment est ce que vous comprenez
qu'aujourd'hui finalement eric dupond
moretti ont fait cette proposition alors
je ne sais pas c'est peut-être son
ancienne expérience professionnelle
qu'il amène à considérer comme moi que
parfois on aurait bien envie quand même
d'avoir des traces de ce qui se dit à
une audience de ce qui s'y déroule
maintenant je comprends qu'il a aussi
envie de faire bouger les lignes mais
est ce que ce sont ces lignes à qu'il
faut faire bouger si on doit dépenser de
l'argent dans une réforme de la justice
il y as peut-être une façon de rendre
cette justice accessibles d'autres
manières que celle de films et de
diffuser comme ça un public non averti
pour en plus pour informer les gens pour
les rendre averti précisément je pense
qu'il ya d'autres moyens en tout cas
nous dans la justice nous avocats au
quotidien il ya des choses dont on
aurait cruellement besoin les magistrats
auraient aussi cruellement besoin de
moyens et nous sommes tous démunis alors
avec cette justice moribonde en valais
la main
très devant des caméras de télévision je
ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire pour moi
ça n'a pas grand sens en revanche il ya
d'autres choses que j'aimerais voir
proposer comme par exemple arrêter de
faire des facs pour accéder à des
greffes les facs n'existe bientôt plus
et on est obligé de faire des vagues
dans certaines circonstances il ya des
réseaux virtuels qui devrait exister
mais qui marchent pas enfin vous voyez
on marche un peu sur la tête
donc moi je veux bien qu'on a démontré
tout ça à la télévision pourquoi pas
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté notre invitation florence rouge
rappelle que vous êtes avocat pénaliste
merci à vous également vincent berger
avocat spécialiste du droit
international